>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
FOR MORE THAN TWO LONG YEARS
THE INSTITUTIONAL LEFT TOLD
US THEY KNEW EXACTLY WHAT
THE MUELLER ROUTER WOULD
SAY.
THEY SAID IT WOULD END THE
TRUMP PRESIDENCY AND SAVE
THIS NATION.
CONGRESSMAN ADAM SCHIFF WHO
SITS ON THE INTEL COMMITTEE
AND WOULD KNOW GAVE US A
PREVIEW.
SCHIFF SAID HE HAD SEEN WITH
HIS OWN EYES PROOF THAT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES INCLUDED CRIMINALLY
WITH THE GOVERNMENT OF
RUSSIA.
BUZZFEED, A NOTED CAT BLOG
SAID IT HAD CONCLUSIVE
EVIDENCE THAT TRUMP
OBSTRUCTED EVIDENCE.
ABC NEWS MOMENTARILY TANKED
STOCK PRICES WHEN IT
REPORTED THAT TRUMP HAD
ORDERED HIS NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR TO TALK TO
THE RUSSIANS AND SO ON.
THE MUELLER REPORT IS GOING
TO PROVE ALL OF THESE
STORIES TRUE.
AND THEN THE REPORT CAME OUT
AND TURNS OUT THAT NONE OF
IT WAS TRUE.
IT WAS ALL A LIE.
HOW DID THE PEOPLE WHO TOLD
AND REPEATED THOSE LIES
RESPOND?
THEY COULD HAVE DONE WHAT
DECENT PEOPLE DO.
THEY COULD HAVE RESIGNED
THEIR JOBS, TEARFULLY
APOLOGIZE FOR MISLEADING OUR
COUNTRY AND MOVED TO
PARAGUAY IN SHAME.
THEY COULD HAVE DONE THAT
BUT THEY DIDN'T.
INSTEAD THEY DO WHAT THEY
ALWAYS DO.
THEY BECAME MORE AGGRESSIVE.
THEY DECIDED THAT ACTUALLY
THE MUELLER REPORT
VINDICATED EVERYTHING THEY
HAVE BEEN SAYING SINCE 2016.
IT'S ALL THERE IT'S JUST
BEING HIDDEN BY THAT
DASTARDLY ATTORNEY GENERAL
ROBERT BARR.
WILLIAM BARR, WHATEVER.
BARR.
UP THERE WITH PAPADOPOULOS
AS AN ENEMY OF THE PEOPLE.
>> JUST HAVING HIM SIT FOR A
HEARING OR LOCKING HIM UP
ENOUGH?
>> I WOULD BE HAPPY TO HAVE
HIM SIT FOR A HEARING AND I
THINK YOU HAVE TO HAVE HIM
LOCKED UP UNLESS HE AGREES
TO PARTICIPATE AND COME TO
THE HEARING.
>> THE HOUSE AND THE SENATE
EACH CHAMBER HAS AN INHERENT
POWER TO COMPEL A WITNESS TO
TESTIFY IF THAT WITNESS JUST
REFUSES.
AND THAT INCLUDES ARREST AND
EVEN INCLUDES JAIL.
THE HOUSE IS POWERLESS
UNLESS THE HOUSE TAKES SOME
ACTION.
>> WE HAVE WHAT'S CALLED
INHERENT CONTEMPT
PROCEEDINGS WHICH MEANS WE
SEND THE SERGEANT OF ARMS
OUT TO HAND GUFF THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DECLINING.
>> WHO ARE YOU GOING TO
HANDCUFF?
>> I'M GOING TO START WITH
MR. BARR.
>> Tucker: CUFF HIM, LOCK
HIM UP.
SEND HIM TO JAIL.
THE MAN WHO IS THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL FOR LESS THAN THREE
MONTHS MUST BE IMPRISONED
FOR HIS CRIMES WHATEVER
THOSE CRIMES ARE AND THE
PRESIDENT MUST GO ON TRIAL
TOO.
YOU MIGHT THINK THAT THE
CLEARANCE OF NO COLLUSION
MUST BE GOOD BUT NO IT MEANS
HE MUST BE IMPEACHED.
>> TO PARTICIPATE IN OUR
ELECTIONS TO OBSTRUCT
JUSTICE AND COVER UP DURING
THE INVESTIGATION.
[CROWD BOOS]
THERE MUST BE
ACCOUNTABILITY.
WE MUST GET BEHIND THE HOUSE
OF REPRESENTATIVES IF THEY
PURSUE IMPEACHMENT OF THIS
PRESIDENT.
[CHEERS]
YOU ALMOST WISH HIS CAMPAIGN
WASN'T OVER SO WE WOULD GET
NEW CLIPS OF THE HAT
BOUNCING AND HAND GESTURES.
DID YOU HEAR WHAT HE SAID?
HE SAID IMPEACHED NO MATTER
WHAT THE COST, IMPEACHMENT
IS A THEOLOGICAL IMPERATIVE.
WATCH.
>> ARE YOU CONCERNED THAT
IMPEACHMENT TALK MAY
ACTUALLY HELP THE
PRESIDENT'S RE-ELECTION?
>> I'M CONCERNED THAT IF WE
DON'T IMPEACH THIS PRESIDENT
HE WILL GET REELECTED.
>> Tucker: IMPEACH HIM
BEFORE THE PEOPLE CHOOSE HIM
AS THEIR PRESIDENT AGAIN.
THAT'S HOW DEMOCRACY WORKS.
NOW, WATCHING ALL THIS YOU
MIGHT ASSUME THAT THE LEFT
HAS LOST CONTROL OF ITSELF
AND YOU WOULD BE HALF RIGHT
THE DEMOCRATIC BASE HAS BEEN
EMOTIONALLY INCONTINENT FOR
QUITE SOME TIME.
THEY ARE GETTING WORSE, NOT
BETTER, AND YOU CAN THANK
THE INTERNET FOR THAT THE
PEOPLE WHO RUN THE PARTY ARE
NOT CRAZY.
THEY ARE COOLEY RATIONAL.
THEY ALWAYS HAVE BEEN.
THEY WANT POWER.
THAT'S ALL THEY WANT,
WHATEVER IT TAKES.
THESE PEOPLE DON'T THROW
FITS UNLESS IT SERVES SOME
HIGHER POLITICAL PURPOSE.
AND THIS FIT DOES SERVE A
HIGHER PURPOSE.
THEY ARE TRYING TO DIVERT
ATTENTION FROM A MUCH BIGGER
STORY.
REMEMBER WHEN TRUMP SAID THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION HAD
BEEN SPYING ON HIS CAMPAIGN?
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY'S BOOT
LIQUORS WENT ABSOLUTELY
CRAZY THE SECOND HE SAID IT
THEY RUSHED TO THE NEAREST
TELEVISION STUDIO TO MOCKET
VERY IDEA.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS A NEW
FAVORITE WORD AND EVERY TIME
HE USES IT, HE IS LYING.
AND THAT IS THE WORD SPY.
>> HIS BASELESS CLAIMS OF
SPIES.
>> SO-CALLED SPY ISSUE,
FIRST OF ALL, THERE IS
ABSOLUTELY NO EVIDENCE THERE
WAS A SPY.
SO IT'S REALLY A FAKE ISSUE.
>> HE WANTS YOU TO BELIEVE
THAT HIS CAMPAIGN WAS SPIED
ON AND IT'S ONE OF THE WORST
THINGS WE HAVE EVER SEEN
FROM GOVERNMENT.
>> Tucker: I THINK LOOKING
BACK THE VCR, ONE OF THE
GREAT INVENTIONS IN HUMAN
HISTORY MAY BE FIRE THE
WHEEL THE VCR IT ALLOWS US
TO PRESERVE PEOPLE'S CLAIMS
ON TAPE AND THEN PLAY THEM
BACK.
THE GROUP YOU JUST SAW WERE
HYSTERICAL AT THE IDEA THAT
TRUMP MIGHT BELIEVE THERE
WAS SPYING ON HIS CAMPAIGN.
THEY WERE HYSTERICAL BECAUSE
THEY SUSPECTED IT MIGHT
ACTUALLY BE TRUE.
AND NOW WE KNOW THAT IT WAS.
IN FACT, ACCORDING TO RECENT
TESTIMONY FROM A
HIGH-RANKING FBI OFFICIAL,
THE SPYING TURNED OUT TO BE
FAR MORE EXTENSIVE THAN
TRUMP EXPECTED, EVEN JAMES
CLAPPER HAD TO CONCEDE THAT.
>> USING UNDER COVER AGENTS
IS A STANDARD AND LEGITIMATE
TECHNIQUE THAT IS WIDELY
USED IN INVESTIGATIONS.
THAT TECHNIQUE HAS BEEN USED
TO THWART A LOT OF
COUNTER-TERRORISM PLOTS IN
THIS COUNTRY SO I'M SURE
THERE ARE PROTOCOLS AND
STANDARDS FOR USING AN AGENT
AND I'M SURE THAT'S THE CASE
HERE.
>> WAS IT SPYING?
>> WELL, YEAH, I GUESS IT
MEETS THE DICTIONARY
DEFINITION OF SPYING -- OF